what's happening there reject nation
greg here today john and i will be
meeting up together again this weekend
in the meantime i'm watching after his
home looking after his lovely cats
keeping his lovely fiance pleasured
we're gonna watch from his lovely best
friend warren from the cosmic wonder
marvel r rated projects major update
talk deadpool 3 blade daredevil punisher
maybe even more the marvel r-rated side
of the mcu is one of the things i'm
hoping comes to the damn multiverse
copper i know john's not here but please
anyway guys leave a like if you can
that'd be great
[Music]
marvel studios is making a little bit of
a change a really really good change
that fans are going to be very excited
about this news means that okay a lot of
good things are about to happen very
soon and are going to happen in the
future and that is it looks like marvel
is indeed going to be embracing their
rated r side
god damn top i know a lot of people were
worried about this with deadpool coming
to the mcu they were worried that marvel
studios and disney in particular were
going to kind of bump him down to a
pg-13 film which would be unfortunate
because that would kind of kill who
deadpool is really he's probably one of
the very few characters that really
needs to be unfiltered but it looks like
marvel studios has a plan it looks like
they're taking action right now actually
with this plan and it all starts with
the marvel netflix shows coming to
disney plus this month you know that's
when i actually heard charlie cox i or i
saw a quote and hear him say if there's
a quote going around of him saying that
he thinks that a pg-13 version of
daredevil could work on disney plus
please don't i'm asking you kindly
please don't could it sure
is it the best choice though that's the
ultimate question this is awesome news
because this means we can get some new
superhero groups and new characters in
the mcu that can all be rated r we can
have a much darker kind of grungier side
of the mcu and this will affect like
that but it will also affect some
characters that we already have some of
the more clean-cut characters so in this
video i'll talk about the new creatures
that we could possibly get and yes we
will be talking about the midnight suns
but also be talking about how characters
and groups like these will affect the
groups like the avengers oh man
there you go this all started with the
marvel netflix series contracts being
done they are now not on netflix anymore
and they are heading to disney plus this
month however for those of you who have
watched these series on netflix like
daredevil and the punisher you know that
they're kind of darker serious they can
be dark and they can be kind of brutal
that's what makes them great they're
actually making some updates and some
changes to their parental controls on
disney plus now what they're doing is
basically adding more parental controls
giving a little bit more customization
to the parents so they can limit or
filter out shows and movies that they
don't want their kids watching now i
know that this doesn't really affect us
that much we want to watch the marvel
shows but this is good news because we
were worried disney plus wasn't really
going to show anything that was rated r
now if you're one of those parents who's
worried about your child accessing this
more r-rated side of television but feel
relieved um
yeah i don't i wouldn't feel relieved
it's gonna be so easy for them to bypass
this [ __ ] it always is they probably
shouldn't be watching this video right
now but this is the first step in marvel
studios and disney going towards a rated
r future because deadpool 3 is right
around the corner in fact ryan reynolds
said that he promises an update soon so
the timing of all of this is kind of
lining up then of course we have moon
night that is coming in it's supposed to
be violent i'm imagining that moon
knight is probably going to be really
like daredevil and like the punisher the
netflix series which again the timing is
kind of perfect here would it be that
r-rated coming right before the release
of moon night about 15 days before and
they're updating their parental settings
so i'm guessing moon knight is going to
live up to the rumors and it is going to
be kind of violent and this is a certain
side of the mcu a more kind of adult
side that they have kind of been lacking
in of course i love everything that's
come out so far but expanding and
growing into different areas is always
good i mean moon knight let's face it
it's probably gonna push
a hard pg-13 at best but the marvel
netflix shows straight up that's rated r
territory either way like i'm super
excited for moon net i i really feel
like that's gonna be one badass show you
know we've seen like the batman recently
that a lot of that felt r-rated in a lot
of tone and style as well and some grit
as long as they keep it pg-13 you can at
least
inch towards the thigh and we also have
blade coming now the original blades
were rated r and side note ryan reynolds
was actually in blade trinity so i think
it would be hilarious that if in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness we
saw blade and then we saw ryan reynolds
and people thought he was wade wilson
deadpool and he's like what no who's
that the potential for that movie is
limitless but anyways
the new blade
rated r as well in fact i think a lot of
people want that the original one was
rated r because well it did have some
cursing in it but it was also very
violent as well but let's think about
this for a second it really does seem
like marvel studios is about to open up
an entirely different side of the mcu
here the perfect example is doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
originally doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness was going to be
directed by scott derrickson he directed
the first doctor strange film which was
great and this one was supposed to be a
horror film and he's done a lot of
r-rated horror movies from what we heard
scott derrickson wanted to really go
full out with a horror film and kevin
feige and marvel kind of told him to
tone it back just a little bit there
were some differences and that's why he
left the project but then marvel studios
hired sam raimi of course we know him
from directing the original spider-man
films but he's also a horror movie
director as well and according to marvel
studios this film still is going to have
several horror aspects to it and this is
really the start along with what one
division did of introducing a more
mystical magical side of the mcu and
with that sometimes it can get pretty
dark you could have dark magic you could
have possessions and we already do have
the darkhold book which was made by an
ancient evil elder god c'thun and with
all of these rumored cameos that are
supposed to happen in multiverse of
madness i'm thinking that this is going
to be the start of a supernatural side
of the marvel cinematic universe i mean
you make an interesting point like i
think blade for the solo movie i think i
feel like a lot of us would agree that
you could maybe get away with a pg-13
movie but then again the question is
will that be the best rating for the
film and i really think for blade to
meet its potential it would fully need
to be r rated man like i love that first
blade movie wesley snipes and i know
this would be a very different
interpretation but it's got to be rated
r but i could see like if he teams up
with other characters he hit whatever
action he's doing or dialogue he's given
that doesn't need to be rated r if
anything i i kind of feel like with
deadpool yeah i would want him to be
kept at a reverent r rated nature even
in crossovers but they'll dial them back
to keep that pg-13 and [ __ ] you know
like open up the supernatural door even
with that you can still just push the
line the insidious film's pg-13 i
thought it was rated r just because of
like how scary i thought it was
but maybe i'm just a [ __ ] but like
supernatural that's the series
supernatural as long as you know like on
television for a long gas time and
they've had to keep it pg-13 for the
most part still so i think as long as
they push the boundaries of what a pg-13
can be we'll be good but some of these
have to be rated r and let's not forget
the marvel netflix series might actually
be kind of canon to the mcu now which
means the punisher could be coming as
well the punisher has to be raided hard
man but rumor has had it for a while
that the midnight suns are indeed going
to be coming in the mcu and with
everybody i just mentioned that would be
a pretty killer midnight suns team and
hopefully by the end of multiverse of
madness one doctor strange is alive and
two scarlet witch becomes good again
because that midnight suns team could be
doctor strange the scarlet witch the
punisher moon knight ghost rider and
blade that would be a pretty awesome can
you imagine that deadpool would make a
great addition to that team as well i'm
just not so sure he would join the team
i mean i really do think that we need a
midnight suns movie because we've
entered like a whole new terrain when it
comes to comic book movies and
especially within the marvel cinematic
universe which is embracing the
multiverse so much i don't really hear
too many people
even really talk about hey what's like
the next official avengers 5 movie
coming out that doesn't really seem to
be on the forefront of people's minds
like we move past it but what if we can
get excited for a different breed of
crossover so if you've got like this
darker supernatural side of the marvel
cinematic universe and hell if morbius
ends up being beloved maybe sony and
marvel workouts to deal with jere
littles orbeez could be in the midnight
sun i just think out of a lot of the
groups that are being formed here you
know it's like part of what made the
avengers feel so special when they first
came together was the build up of their
individual films if we could replicate
that again but with just a very
different side of the mcu that would be
so awesome and i think deadpool would
make a great addition to that team as
well i'm just not so sure he would join
the team and like i mentioned in the
beginning of the week i think it would
be really really cool to see a team like
this the midnight suns interact with a
team like the avengers because you have
to imagine that somebody like the
punisher and somebody like deadpool
going around killing people that's not a
good look for superheroes and that look
could affect the avengers because
they'll probably associate with each
other and there's a lot that i'd
actually like to see from this one i
would love to see the banter between
deadpool and some really good heroes
like clean cut heroes like can you
imagine deadpool having a conversation
with captain america either captain
america steve rogers or sam wilson or
imagine deadpool talking to somebody
like captain marvel there are so many
jokes that they could feel
especially since deadpool can break the
fourth wall i'd actually really love to
see loki and deadpool have a
conversation i think that would be a
pretty witty conversation but i can even
see the new avengers team stepping in at
some point in time to stop a team like
the midnight suns from going and doing
something and the two teams fighting
each other kind of like a civil war i
think for whatever team comes next after
we've built up their individual
properties and they come together
whatever threat they first versed
shouldn't be another team that we're
familiar with like the avengers i just
don't think that i want that eventually
don't get me wrong that like that sounds
awesome i do think that for their first
outings it should be like a very special
villain like you gotta establish the
necessity for why these individuals have
come together but there is so much
potential to marvel studios and disney
opening up this more r-rated side of the
mcu potential for it to get a lot
grittier a lot funnier and just bigger
and more diverse in general
let me know what you think thanks for
the info warren that was wonderful one
day john will let me join you guys on a
phone call guys subscribe because we
wonder if you haven't done so already
you can subscribe to the real rejects
almost at a million subscribers yay it's
a fancy looking number thank you guys
you have joined us so far leave a like
and uh last but not least i want to do
i want to shout out a man named jean
jeter now gene we've talked in private
uh but i'm going to take a moment here
to just be sincere gene i just want to
say thank you that for all these years
you have been very understanding and you
have shown your support for us when
we were having a hard time just even
getting by you've been with us for such
a long time i'll never ever forget that
we could get bigger than ever i'll never
forget just how gracious you've been to
us for so long uh gene is a hard working
dude there's a whole bunch of different
content on his youtube channel has a
wonderful instagram full of beautiful
people he's overall just a really nice
inventive gentleman jean just want to
hop on here and say thank you for
everything
and uh you're
you're a gem in our lives and i really
want you to know that thank you
[Music]